welcome back to Hannity joining us now
on this breaking news night with full
reaction to the news is the author of
the number one bestseller rediscovering
Americanism and the tyranny of
progressivism a rare appearance it's
hard to grab this guy out of his bunker
radio talk-show host I call him the
great one Mark Levin mark great to see
you I I truly honestly in my heart of
hearts wish we didn't have to talk about
this again the president is right about
vetting if you come from these countries
with these really sick ideologies and
oppression of innocent people what about
people that are here that we never
vetted
you can't even vet people that aren't
here without being called racist and
Islamophobic don't we need to do a
better job of understanding those that
may have bought into the sick twisted
ideology yeah there's no question about
it but what's very interesting about
this mass killer he came here in 2010 so
he was 22 years old he wasn't a four
year old who came across the border with
his mother he came here he was 22 years
old and he came under a program called
the diversity visa program I started
digging into this you know what that is
Sean it's a lottery program it's been in
existence for some time 50,000 people a
year coming here through the diversity
visa program because the diversity visa
program was set up you see to make sure
that underrepresented countries can send
their people into this country - and he
did that in 2010 the program started
before 1990 but in 1990s when the
current program was put into law under
the Immigration Act
you know the sponsor was Chuck Schumer
the senior senator of New York good
grief it was put it and it took effect
in 1995 people go online and they apply
they apply online and it's a lottery
system that's no way to run an
immigration system that is Haller on my
radio program tonight Young said used to
work counterintelligence al Qaeda and
Isis have actively been working to use
this program to put sleepers in our
country this mass killer has claimed an
association with Isis hasn't he this
diversity visa program should be gutted
we
need a diversity visa program with
50,000 people a year come into this
country through a lottery system because
we want diversity from different
countries and we seem to forget the
purpose of immigration historically the
purpose of immigration is to improve the
United States is to benefit the United
States not to ensure diversity from
foreigners coming into this country not
to ensure that certain countries are
well represented or even certain
refugees are coming here from wherever
they're coming from immigration is
supposed to improve the United States it
has nothing to do with improving other
countries and so forth also some of your
guests said something that I agree with
a hundred percent you know Barack Obama
pulled our FBI agents and other people
out of these mosques we need physical
individuals FBI agents whomever they are
to monitor certain situations pew did a
study a couple years ago and I have it
in my book plunder and deceit pew not me
Hugh did a study they surveyed American
Muslims throughout the country over 80%
of them said not enough is being done by
the leadership in their own community in
the United States to tap down the
violent rhetoric and so forth five
percent said that vote of here people
who are here five percent said violence
is acceptable now the vast majority say
no and we keep saying the vast majority
say no but when are we going to have an
honest discussion about this we have
discussions about race every other day
we have discussions about everything
every day but this issue is taboo
because people don't want to destroy
their careers or we're told that you're
a bigot if you bring it we're not a
bigot if we bring it up
we're not condemning Muslims we're
condemning people who promote violence
and when they yell what they yell after
they attack people they've confessed
they've self-identified as to who they
are so in many respects it is an
immigration issue you know mark it seems
so basic it seems so fundamental it's
it's what we call simple common sense
and that is that okay in the light in
light of the death the destruction the
stated intent to kill innocent men women
and children in the name of this
fanatical radical Islamic ideology to
is basic common sense that you if you
want the honor of getting into this
country one you should do it legally -
we just need to know that you're not
going to want to kill us and similarly
we probably have let many people in that
do have extreme ideologies now you're a
constitutional authority how do you do
this thread the needle between the use
of intelligence vetting people
protecting the Fourth Amendment their
constitutional rights and also
protecting the American people it's a
it's a harder question that then it
seems on the surface it's a harder
question because you do have due process
rights in some respects depending on the
status of the individual ok the other
problem is 40% of the federal judiciary
is filled with Obama appointees so when
the president United States does
something that's perfectly rational and
they go judge something follows the
statute they're finding judges in
Honolulu and Baltimore in Seattle who
are Obama judges how many Reagan judges
how many even Bush judges have been
involved in any of these immigration
decisions very very few and what they're
doing is the courts have now
nationalized the immigration issue with
the president's hands are tied this is
absurd I mean these are the same
leftists who used to cheer FDR and claim
that he's the greatest president in
American history FDR was rounding up
japanese-americans and Americans of
Japanese descent and they love FDR
Donald Trump is following the
Constitution following the statute
trying to protect America I mean we even
have a federal judge who talks about due
process rights for aliens before they
even come to the United States to
determine whether they should be here
this is progressivism gone nuts and it's
funny people and they would have thought
after 9/11 that people would take this
issue of immigration seriously
immigration is about national security
near exactly right once people get into
the country becomes far more complicated
so you want to stop them at the border
and when the President of the United
States said as he did when he first came
into office we can't vet these people
some of these governments are at
effective war with us some of them don't
exist some of them are involved in civil
wars you know we can't
all Yemen and say hey can you check this
dye out on your computer system there is
no computer sister if there is no
effective government and what the
president is saying you can't take the
wrench you can't bring people in from
these countries until we figure out
what's going on you know it's so funny
what you said about this president being
constitutional because on the issue of
daca it was Barack Obama who said I
don't have the power to act unilaterally
and it was President Trump that
respected co-equal branches of
government separation of powers things
you discuss all the time all right we
don't running out of time I want to get
into a couple of issues we have this
whole uranium one scandal our national
security was sold out now we learn that
Muller Rosenstein Holder all knew about
bribery racketeering extortion money
laundering all happening in 2009 holders
still signed off on it
Muller is investigating Muller is
imported by Rosenstein between that and
the Trump dossier that Clinton the DNC
and Obama paid for bought and paid for
Russian lies propaganda to impact the
American people on election I've got to
know what you think about this but it to
me there is the real Russia conspiracy
collusion what's worse than collusion
isn't it you know 50 60 70 years ago if
any politicians any administration had
conferred control over 20% of America's
uranium to the Russians what do you
think would happen what do you think
would happen I mean that would be
considered an absolute unbelievable act
of treason now I use this word treason
because the Democrats made it popular
when they were attacking Donald Trump
jr. for having a meeting but you take
those two cases I'll tell you something
else about Muller let me jump right into
his indictment of Manafort and gates if
I may just briefly to show you what an
incompetent this guy is and yet what an
iron-fisted out-of-control prosecutor
this guy's I read his indictment it's
irrational first he uses a marque above
one of the segments says conspiracy
against the United States now most
normal prosecutors put conspiracy but he
puts it out for the press because the
press is stupid and the press wants to
say what Muller is saying cuz
Spira see against the united states like
these one of the Rosenbergs or something
which of course a man affording gates or
not
let's take a look quickly at the money
laundering to evade taxes is one of the
reasons right but they don't charge them
with tax evasion so you're evading taxes
and you don't charge them with tax
evasion what's that all about
honestly I don't know to evade
registering as a foreign agent to evade
registering as a foreign agent so he's
laundering money that charges one of
those never know what it is it's a
misdemeanor yeah you're telling me a man
commits a felony to cover up a
misdemeanor that doesn't make a hell of
a lot of sense to me then we talk about
foreign bank accounts they're unreported
right we got 2128 on those funds yeah
we're taxes paid on those funds well he
didn't charge them with tax evasion I
guess they were I don't know money
laundering you've got a role mark and
money all right well I listen I'd love
to have you more come back more often